greatest violence in the Middle East is
Raising tensions between Israelis and
Palestinians two Palestinians fired
gunshots at a gas station near an
Israeli settlement in the West Bank
yesterday killing four Israelis on the
scene the Islamic group Hamas has
claimed responsibility now this attack
follows a violent clash in the city of
Jaheen on Monday Israeli troops raided a
refugee camp and then helicopter
gunships were sent in to help Evacuate
the soldiers six Palestinians were
killed including a 15-year-old teenager
and 90 people were wounded the state
department says the U.S is concerned
about the escalating violence and will
continue to work with Israeli and
Palestinian authorities to calm things
down